and today a very defeated frankly
pathetic looking joe biden well he
sauntered out to the podium
90 minutes late to deliver these very
uninspiring remarks take a look
and if russia goes further with this
invasion we stand prepared to go further
as with sanctions
who in the lord's name does putin think
gives them the right to declare
new so-called countries
on territory that belong to his
neighbors yesterday
the world heard clearly
the full extent of vladimir putin's
twisted rewrite of history
going back more than a century as he
waxed eloquently
noting
that well i'm not going to go into it
but nothing in putin's let the remarks
indicate any interest in pursuing real
dialogue on european security in the
year 2022.
you know no no doubt vladimir putin is
just shaking in his boots
this is really beyond humiliating for
our country now of course biden did
announce new sanctions today but as one
top russian diplomat put it moscow
doesn't give an adam schiff about any
sanctions and why would they russians
make russia's main source of revenue is
in the form of the production of oil and
gas china they buy a tremendous
tremendous amount of this gas and so
does western europe our allies because
we're not producing it for them and
making money and creating jobs and
lowering this 40-year high of inflation
make no mistake that oil and gas will
continue to flow no matter what russia
does in ukraine in fact much of europe
especially germany well they're
dependent on russian oil and gas which
is a big part of this problem now last
year even america our country joe
biden's first year in office imported a
whopping 230 million barrels of oil from
russia putin's russia joe's been begging
russia opec repeatedly and being
rejected repeatedly to produce more oil
to drive down the price of oil and the
price of a gallon of gasoline
we have more than they have why don't we
produce it ourselves joe this is madness
this is insanity for years many of the
world's leaders have been perfectly
happy to make putin and russia rich
again and a cheap supply of energy
available for all now in 2018 what we're
about to show you is an epic
face-to-face complete beatdown with then
president donald trump rebuking european
leaders getting right in their face for
their dependence on russia for their
energy helping make russia rich again
while we pay the bill for nato to
protect them from russia it's a long
clip
it's worth watching while you're
watching ask yourself do you think joe
biden could ever be capable of this
level of passionate fighting for what is
in our country's best interest here's
the full exchange
i think
it's very
sad when germany makes a massive oil and
gas deal with russia
where you're supposed to be guarding
against russia and germany goes out and
pays billions and billions of dollars a
year to russia so we're protecting
germany we're protecting france we're
protecting all of these countries
and then numerous of the countries go
out and make a pipeline deal with russia
where they're paying
billions of dollars into the golfers of
russia
so we're supposed to protect you against
russia
but they're paying billions of dollars
to russia and i think that's very
inappropriate and the former chancellor
of germany is the head of the pipeline
company that's applying the gas
ultimately germany will have almost 70
percent
of their country
controlled by
russia with natural gas so you tell me
is that appropriate i mean i've been
complaining about this
from the time i got it it should have
never been allowed to have happened but
germany is totally controlled by russia
because they were getting from 60 to 70
percent of their energy
from russia and a new pipeline and you
tell me if that's appropriate because i
think it's not and i think it's a very
bad thing for nato and i don't think it
should have happened
and i think we have to talk to germany
about it on top of that
germany is just paying a little bit over
one percent
whereas the united states in actual
numbers is paying 4.2 percent
of a much larger gdp
so i think that's an appropriate also
you know we're protecting germany we're
protecting france we're protecting
everybody
and yet we're paying a lot of money to
protect now this has been going on for
decades
this has been brought up by other
presidents but other presidents never
did anything about it
because i don't think they understood it
or they just didn't want to get involved
but i have to bring it up because i
think it's very unfair to our country
it's very unfair to our taxpayer
and i think that these countries have to
step it up not over a 10-year period
they have to step it up immediately
germany is a rich country they talk
about they're going to increase it a
tiny bit
by 2030.
well they could increase it immediately
tomorrow
and have no problem i don't think it's
fair to the united states so
we're going to have to do something
because we're not going to put up with
it we can't put up with it and
it's inappropriate
so
we have to talk about the billions and
billions of dollars that's being paid to
the country that we're supposed to be
protecting you against
you know everybody's everybody's talking
about it all over the world they'll say
well wait a minute we're supposed to be
protecting you from russia
but why are you paying billions of
dollars
to russia for energy why are countries
in
nato namely germany having a large
percentage of their energy needs paid
you know to russia and taken care of by
russia now if you look at it
germany is a captive of russia because
they supply they got rid of their coal
plants they got rid of their nuclear
they're getting so much of the oil and
gas from russia i think it's something
that nato has to look at i think it's
very inappropriate you and i agree that
it's inappropriate i don't know what you
can do about it now but it certainly
doesn't seem to make sense that
they pay billions of dollars to russia
and now we have to defend them against
russia you know
nato is an alliance of 29 nations and
there are sometimes differences and
different views and also some
disagreements and the gas
pipeline from russia to germany is one
issue where allies disagree but the
strength of nato is that despite these
differences we have always been able to
unite around our four tasks to protect
and defend each other because we
understand that we are stronger together
than uh
i think the two world wars and the cold
war was that we are stronger together
than apart
but how can you be together when a
country is getting its energy from
the person you want protection against
or from the group that you want
protection because we understand that
when we stand together also in uh
dealing with russia we are stronger i
think what we have seen is that are you
just making russia richer well not
dealing with russia making russia richer
i think that even during the cold war uh
nato allies were trading with russia
then there have been disagreements about
what kind of uh trade arrangements we
should
i think trade is wonderful i think
energy is a whole different story
i think energy is a much different story
than normal trade
and you have a country like poland that
won't accept
the gas you take a look at some of the
countries that won't accept it because
they don't want to be captive to russia
but germany as far as i'm concerned is
captive to russia because it's getting
so much of its energy from russia so
we're supposed to protect germany but
they're getting their energy
from russia explain that and it can't be
explained you know
president did that with no notes right
in the face of the leader of nato and uh
you think joe biden can do that
former secretary of state mike pompeo
who you just saw on that video we'll
have more on that exchange later in the
show tonight but clearly trump was
absolutely dead on accurate now compare
that to joe biden a self-proclaimed
tough guy foreign policy expert he could
go toe-to-toe with putin he promised to
stop putin in his tracks well today
biden could barely form a coherent
sentence as per usual and was unwilling
and unable to respond to any questions
about vladimir take a look
all right well thank you
yes thank you
now you got to let me know when i'm
supposed to stop here but uh
um
sylvia
very silly there you are sylvia
how are you sylvia
this
we have a mumbling bumbling buffoon as
president and tomorrow joe has zero
events scheduled none whatsoever that
doesn't exactly inspire confidence in
the american people but press secretary
jenn saki she knows who to blame for
russia's aggression oh let's blame
donald trump real really jen take a look
does the white house any have any
reaction to former president trump
calling putin's move yesterday genius
and smart
well as a matter of policy
we try not to take advice from anyone
who praises president putin and his
military strategy which i believe is
what happened there so there's a bit of
a different tactic a bit of a different
approach and that's probably why
president biden and not his predecessor
was able to rally the world and the
global community in taking steps against
against russia's aggression hey jen as a
matter of tactic this didn't happen
under donald trump your boss joe created
this problem with his economic and
energy dependency policies joe is
humiliating our entire country on the
world stage he's getting rolled by putin
it is embarrassing and he can barely
string together a sentence and i doubt
he even knows what day of the week it is
joe rogan even said biden is uh
basically a cognitive shell of his
former self look at this
i didn't has been in politics his whole
life like he understands how the senate
works and so forth so does that not
count as experience it kind of does it
kind of does but not as being well he
actually was vice president for eight
years right yeah but he's just
he's not a good example because he's
basically a shell yeah you know like
cognitively you don't see that this guy
can't he's can't talk right anymore go
watch videos of him from 20 years ago
he was a he's a dummy he said a lot of
silly he lied about a bunch of things
but at least he was articulate
joe rogan we've showed videos from 2008
2012 2016
yeah everybody notices the obvious
cognitive decline our friends know it
and unfortunately our enemies also know
it and that includes vladimir putin so
now here's an important question where
do putin's territorial ambitions end
because in 2008 putin invaded georgia
and set up a puppet government he also
set up so-called client states in
moldava
uh and belarus right and under obama in
2014 remember that's when they annexed
crimea now he's rolling into eastern
ukraine with kiev and his crosshairs
what's next based on his own public
remarks he seems pretty hell-bent on
restoring the old soviet union and
recently putin added all three baltic
countries to his official list of
so-called unfriendly nations so what are
they soon now going to be targets of
vladimir putin's territorial ambitions
and if they are what's joey going to do
about it one article put it this way
quote baltic citizens worry they are
next on russia's menu now remember the
baltic states are members of nato so
does that mean the u.s would be drawn
into a war i certainly hope and pray not
especially with this guy as
commander-in-chief but as you can see
this has the potential to spiral way out
of control very quickly weakness should
not be an option that's all i'm seeing
right now it is time for germany and
nato and europe our western european
allies to break free of their dependence
on russian oil and gas the only answer
the only country that has more natural
resources oil gas coal that would be us
the united states and if you really want
to beat putin we're not going to have a
shooting war with putin i don't want one
you shouldn't have one we should flood
the market with our own energy supply
that will help with inflation create
high paying career jobs it's going to be
good for national security and it's time
for europe to get serious about nato
they must pay their fair share they must
take their own defense seriously they
must deter future transgressions from
russia they must stop making russia and
putin richer than ever and of course
that would require bold leadership and
right now the world is missing a u.s
president with a backbone and sadly joe
biden is not up to the job
jennifer griffin has been very very very
articulate in expressing the urgency of
this moment and she'll join us in a
moment but a quick flashback 1980 42
years ago today the u.s men's hockey
team remember they upset the heavily
favored russian team ultimately won gold
remember the hit movie miracle on ice
just to remind you
coming to you from the olympic ice area
the u.s huge underdogs
[Applause]
tomorrow five seconds left in the game
[Applause]
42 years ago tonight al michaels and
what was one of the most epic sports
calls of all time do you believe in
miracles we need one now a few short
years later the berlin wall would come
crashing down the cold war would be over
we bankrupted russia the former soviet
union and here we are under biden
fighting some of the same old battles
with the same old foe hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else